[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show
there is uh as we talked about on the
broadcast show today there
are ev everybody's looking for what to
do to prevent
a crazy covet situation in the fall
basically
and one of the uh ideas that's kind of
floating around
is that of giving people third doses of
a vaccine
and then there's also some reporting
about doctors who initially got the
one-shot j
j vaccine going and getting themselves
one or even two shots of
one of the mrna vaccines pfizer or
moderna
and a lot of this stuff is relatively
speculative i mean getting j
and j and then getting moderna the idea
is jnj is one type of coverage and it
works one way
the mrna vaccines work a different way
so the idea is you would be covered
in multiple ways and there's no reason
to think that the vaccines conflict
the other question is around what about
one shot of pfizer and then one of
moderna
and the who is saying don't do it
because we just don't really know much
about it now this is one of those things
where
i get why the who is saying it at the
same time
the modern and physical vaccines are
essentially clones of each other
and so more than likely
this is fine to do but at the same time
there's really no reason to do it and
it's not clear there's any benefit
so it does make sense to avoid it's one
of those weird things pat where it's
like
it's probably fine but they do need to
be careful but at the same time there's
really no benefit so why is it even
something people are doing
yeah it probably is fine but it's the
type of thing that you need to test
right and so that testing period takes
some time and you have to test
the different combinations like if you
get one shot of pfizer first and then
you get johnson and johnson you got to
test that if you're going to get
one shot of modern and then you get
fizer you gotta test that so there's all
these different iterations and that
could take some time to test
it's kind of the same thing with uh
approving the vaccines for
younger people like we have every reason
to believe that it's probably fine
for people under what 12 years old to be
getting these vaccines but sometimes
vaccines
affect children differently than they do
adults so they want extra testing and
all that stuff
it's just to be extra safe i think and
that makes sense now a lot of this
you know the pfizer moderna one is kind
of a simple one
a lot of these concerns are more related
to things that are happening in places
like in the u.s you might hear like
why would you do that there's millions
and millions of vaccines available if i
want to get
to moderna or to pfizer everything's
available it's all at my fingertips
in other parts of the world where you
know we go often by what the cdc says
rather than the who or we sort of look
at both or the cdc looks at who
in many parts of the world there's like
an initial astrazeneca dose
and then some news about astrazeneca
comes out and some people
become hesitant so they go okay well
i'll go and get myself a fives or dose
when that's available but there's
probably not yet enough pfizer
it might not be clear why anyone would
do this in the u.s but in other parts of
the world
this this is like how you get yourself
vaccinated potentially
yeah and it is a risk assessment of
course because there could be some risk
with mixing vaccines but does that
outweigh
the risk of not becoming fully
vaccinated yeah like if you get that
first pfizer dose for example but then
you can't get another pfizer for
whatever reason so you look at moderna
or another option like is that better
overall
uh when you look at the entire
population of people than it would be to
just stick with the one dose so like all
these things have to be weighed by these
public health
experts the other thing that we're
already thinking about is
even though for now the cdc is saying
people don't need
third doses of the same vaccine we have
at a certain point and i don't know
whether it's going to be the fall
or early winter the vaccine that's
available for kovid
is going to be a slightly different
vaccine than the one that was available
in january of 2020 in that it will be
modified
based on the variants that are now
prevalent and in theory that would
include
the delta variant at that point there's
already the question
if you got like for example i got my two
modernity doses in february
would it be necessary for me to get a
moderna modified booster
next february or could i get a pfizer
again
it's still being studied and we're just
going by the science but
there's every belief that if you got
your full two dose regimen
in 2020 that if there's a modified
booster in 2022
i'm sorry if you got your two dose
regimen in 2021
that if there's a modified booster in 22
that it wouldn't matter you could go and
get fiser booster even if you got modern
that's the belief but again it's like we
just have to wait and see what
ultimately is determined
yep and when pfizer announced that
they're working on a booster shot
for uh people who have received the
first two but you know maybe after some
time because of the bearings and stuff
you'll need a third
um there was this initial pushback i
think from
the cdc and these other government
organizations saying like
okay well pfizer can go ahead and
develop that but you know we don't know
if you necessarily need it yet we know
that the vaccines are effective and i
think that was good because i think a
lot of people are skeptical about
getting the vaccines in the first place
because
of skepticism over big pharma and this
idea that
this is just being done so pfizer and
these other companies can make a bunch
of money
but if there really is pushback from
these government agencies saying like
hold on there
we don't know if we need it yet then i
think that can sort of relieve some of
that skepticism
the other thing i want to get back to
and maybe next week or the week after
is thanks to
the pfizer and modern mrna coveted
vaccines
there is now significant advancement on
an mrna-based flu vaccine and one of the
big criticisms of flu shots is some
some years they're only 20 percent
effective um
the idea is that a an mrna-based flu
vaccine
maybe we just don't know yet may be
significantly more effective
we'll get we'll get back to that there
is the recall election moving forward in
the state of california where even
though california
is doing well financially it's doing
well economically
standard of living is is on average
quite high
although of course averages can be
deceptive when you've got
really really well-off people and and
people that are doing terribly
education is is very good in california
health care is some of the best in the
country in kelp okay they want to recall
gavin newsom anyway fine
gavin newsom is going to appear on the
recall ballots
without his democratic party label
this was a legal fight that finished for
now yesterday
and newsom's team was scrambling to try
to fix an error
which is now going to lead to him being
on the ballot without a d next to his
name and newsome sued the secretary of
state
saying the law imposes a needlessly
early deadline
for recall targets to request party
designation
and that now he is going to be deprived
having his party
listed on the ballot and that this is
going to deprive voters
of information now this is really really
interesting because
what's really at issue here pat what's
at issue here is
gavin newsom's campaign accurately
assesses
there's people who barely know who he is
who vote
down party line and the belief is if i
don't have a d
next to my name there are people who
might not vote for me in the recall
simply because they're looking for d and
they don't see it and
it's a sad commentary on the way that
politics
works but it's an accurate commentary
yeah and it's not just a problem in this
race too like there's a debate over
whether or not party affiliation should
be
next to candidates names in all races
yeah and i can kind of see
both sides of the argument there uh
because you know in some sense like
people are more than just their parties
but
at the same time it kind of is helpful
to know who's a democrat and republican
because like
people often match up pretty close to
their party affiliations and you may not
know the specifics of every race yeah
especially down ballot especially when
you get beyond like the governors and
the senators and stuff like that
when you're looking at like you know uh
city council members and that type of
thing
and you didn't really do your research
ahead of the time when you're voting
maybe it is helpful to see those d's and
r's
um so i can kind of see both sides when
it comes to that but yeah in this case
it seems like more of a technicality i
don't think it will affect the race
though
yeah my thought on this has been there's
a lot of local races like for example
back when the show was based in
northampton massachusetts and i would
sometimes moderate
mayoral debates though the mayoral
they're basically all democrats for all
the candidates all the winners you know
it's just all democrats in northampton
massachusetts but
there's no party does it's not a
partisan election in that the candidates
don't show up with a d or an r next to
their name
and they're such hyper local races where
it really is about
um policy related to streets policy
related to school
the i don't think that there's any
relevance between the national
democratic and republican platforms or
even the state democratic and republican
platforms and like what the mayor of
northampton is going to do
i also believe that everybody should be
researching individual candidates and
evaluating every race based on
individual candidates that's what i do
but like this is my job so i understand
i'm in a different position
it's not illegitimate to say i as a
voter
um you might vote in a particular
district say
in you might live in new york city right
and on a ballot you might have
presidential election u.s senator
member of congress state senator
state rep new york city mayor city
council all this different stuff
um although they're not all
representative
of like the national and state party
platforms
it's not completely nuts to say hey you
know what
i just don't have the time to research
nine races
but right now i looked at the republican
platform
federally and at the state level and i
looked at the democratic platform
and like i'm just really close to the
democratic platform so my plan is to
vote for democrats
that's not crazy to be like that you
know i i would love to say
you should research every race every
candidate but i do think that it's
valuable information and certainly for a
gubernatorial election it should be on
there
right we'd like people to be able to
research every single race and every
single candidate but we just know that's
not very realistic especially when
voter turnout on average is below 50 to
begin with it's like an extra step to
try to encourage people to
learn more about the candidates
specifically and that's just kind of
asking a lot of voters at the end of the
day so i do agree i think it probably
makes sense in most cases
uh to keep the d's and r's but in some
other cases like with those
local races where party affiliation
matters less maybe you can leave it out
um but yeah it'll be interesting to see
how it affects this race in california i
don't think uh gavin newsom is
really at risk here being recalled based
on the polling that i've seen and yes
and the fact that
there really aren't any significant
challengers that are uh coming at him
like i know uh larry elder announced
that he's going to be running uh and of
course caitlyn jenner is going to be
running but
the republicans just haven't been able
to win in california for a long time and
i don't think they're going to start now
when arnold schwarzenegger challenged
gray davis during that recall
the polling was very clear that gray
davis was in trouble and that arnold
schwarzenegger had a real shot there's
no equivalent
to that right now yep and that was a
very different time that was almost 20
years ago at this point and the
republican party is very very different
at this point it's the trump party and
there aren't that many trumpers in
california there are some
uh you know enough to trigger this
recall and all that stuff there is some
presence but not enough to win
hey so this is an interesting story
there's a new report
that 60 so this is like this is such a
definitional story that i'll give you
the headline then we have to get into
the details
there's a report that sixty percent of
millennials
self-report earning over a hundred
thousand dollars a year
and that they are living paycheck to
paycheck so like what's a millennial
how valuable is self-reporting and what
does it mean to live paycheck to
paycheck
okay yeah good so we've gotta define all
of these things so let's see first of
all
um the sel can we are people being
honest about self-reporting their
income probably yeah i mean i don't
think that that the
deception about income is really the
issue here
um millennials millennials are
defined as oh now i do is it 1982
to yeah where when is it so like 96 or
97.
i know that you are at the high range of
millennials
and i'm at the lower range of the
millennial age group
yeah i'm actually trying to pull it up
right now uh so let's see here
um early 80s to
mid 90s but then some include even
early 2000s i guess the widely accepted
range is 81 to 96 so it's people who are
between
40 on the high end and 25 on the low end
right now okay so that's how we're
defining millennial
and then what does it mean to be
paycheck to paycheck um
that you know paycheck sometimes people
say well paycheck to paycheck is
you are quote barely scraping by and
just out of poverty
that's not really accurate and paycheck
to paycheck particularly when you have
access to debt and you have a credit
card
means something very very different and
unfortunately there was no specific
definition given
of paycheck to paycheck but let's let's
sort of explore this
um if you're uh so there's there's two
different reactions to this
one is six figures and your paycheck to
paycheck how is that that's
simply bad budgeting that's one side of
this thing
okay the other side is well okay
if you have student loan debt which is
unprecedented for millennials
relative to wages that they expect to
earn because of the cost of college
and wages are stagnant and you live
in a major metropolitan area that have
like the highest rents i think the three
are new york san francisco washington dc
if you make a hundred and one thousand
dollars a year
and have you know an 800 a month
or even more student loan payment and
your rent is
some outrageous amount maybe it's not
crazy it's
maybe it's not really just bad budgeting
maybe that's actually just the reality
for millennials
um my concern is that
definitionally this is very fast and
loose and everything is sort of like
do you believe that you are paycheck to
paycheck and it's a combination of
people who don't know how to budget
and people who have just taken on more
fixed costs than they necessarily need
to
and people being crushed by student debt
and people being crushed by high
health care expenditures it's a very
difficult thing to just overall make an
assessment of
yeah i think first of all i do suspect
that maybe people
are inflating their personal incomes a
little bit
maybe just as a way to brag or i don't
know it may not be a tremendous amount
but maybe like 20
extra they give themselves or something
like that and uh the definition of
paycheck to paycheck i've always thought
of
is that like if your income went to zero
um
would you be able to make your expenses
for the next month or so like would you
be able to pay your rent and all that do
you have enough savings to be able to
maintain your standard of living that's
generally my belief yeah and you know we
i've talked before about the levels of
emergency funds and it's like the first
thing is do you have a thousand dollars
saved the next thing is could you afford
a month of expenses if your income went
to zero
and then it's do you have a four to six
month buffer
of zero income and for me i agree
paycheck to paycheck is
your next month if your income was zero
you can't meet all of your expenses
without going into debt
yep and then uh when it comes to some of
these things like student loan payments
and that sort of thing you don't really
have that much
control over it you know once you're out
of college and working all that stuff
um i guess you could refinance and that
sort of thing but that gets obviously
tricky
you do have some control over where you
live especially this day and age after
covid where you know you can seek a job
where you can work
remotely and then maybe you can decide
to work in or live in somewhere that's
uh more rural and that sort of thing and
so you can bring your uh cost of housing
down but
oftentimes millennials especially don't
want to live in those more rural areas
because
they tend to be less fun right i mean
people seek like the nightlife and
the city living environment especially
when they're young because many people
just find that to be more entertaining
to themselves
so like some of these things are within
people's control obviously you can like
scale down
the apartment or house that you're
living in if you want to be able to save
more and not live
paycheck to paychecks so much so there
is some that are
there that's in control here but i don't
want to uh sound like i'm a millennial
basher here because no no no
too often millennials get the short end
of the stick with it it's a very
complicated thing and one of the
interesting things that is starting to
happen or that is that could happen
that i've been reading about is um one
of the reasons
that salaries are higher in cities is
because cost of living is higher in
cities
one of the reasons that cost of living
is higher in cities
is because people expect to make more in
cities it's a sort of like circular
thing one of the impacts
of more remote work uh
is both that the cost of living in
cheaper areas
will go up and that the average salary
for some jobs will go down and the way
that this would happen is
if you are a business in new york city
and you have a position that
historically
you've paid a hundred thousand dollars a
year for
based on what you needed to pay to make
sense for new york city
when you can now hire from the entire
country including places that are really
cheap to live
you're gonna find tons of people in
tulsa oklahoma for example
that would be very willing to do that
job for fifty thousand dollars and so
now that the whole country
is potentially uh uh qualified for the
job that you're offering
you are going to see downward pressure
on wages for that job as a result but
then there's the other side of this
the people with the higher salaries from
the cities
who say hey i want to be able to afford
more cost more life by going to a
cheaper place
if a lot of the people from new york san
francisco boston miami etcetera say hey
you know what
tulsa's really cheap let's go there whoa
when i'm hitting my microphone
that is going to increase pressure in an
upwards motion
on rent and real estate in tulsa and
that is going to come up so
one of the it's it's not going to be we
now have one housing market and one job
market
of course the united states is still
huge but it could lead to an
equalization to some degree
of wages and rents nationally yeah i was
wondering like do you think overall this
will balance out that is
the hope of course i think with a lot of
stuff right now
post pandemic things are up in the air
like we're seeing a little boost in
inflation but we suspect that maybe that
will level out over the next few months
but you know when you're thinking about
economic impacts especially long-term
it's hard to predict no one can actually
accurately predict what's going to
happen people can only guess and the
other thing is also
it's not like rural montana is even
in the same sort of market as like let
me see if i can say this in a different
way
um the you may have a situation
where cheaper cities become a little
more expensive
and expensive cities become a little bit
cheaper and the wage gap
between expensive and cheap cities
closes a little bit
it's not like rural you know like to
give an example from western
massachusetts it's not like
chester massachusetts is all of a sudden
going to cost the same as boston because
it's just different markets people who
are interested in cities versus people
who are interested in rural so
even the idea that it would become one
equalized market isn't the case
but among cities or among medium cost of
living cities versus high cost of living
you might see that gap sort of narrowing
a little bit and i don't know ultimately
what the answer is
we did cover though the idea that
everybody's saying oh
cities will now be super cheap because
everybody's leaving young people are
flocking back to new york city already
pat and
and that's exactly what we predicted
yeah i saw you talked about on the that
on the bonus show yesterday
um for a long time there have been like
periods where people say that
living in cities is over for people like
when crime was bad in new york city like
the 70s and 80s people were saying that
that like the city model is over with
and
people are going to flee to suburbs more
and more but that didn't happen
people returned to the cities and then
you know everyone left the cities during
covid which made a lot of sense because
you don't want to be around too many
people you don't want to get yourself
sick
sure but now that we're reaching the
post pandemic phase people are flocking
right back to the cities because that's
where people want to be many of us so
i think you know a lot of this stuff can
balance out all right send me your
thoughts on this
we're here uh we're here all week i'll
see everybody tomorrow